From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Keep this in mind. There is another quart of oil in the trunk of the car.
记住这一点。后备箱里还有一夸脱机油。
OK, I'll take the Corolla.
好吧，那我就开卡罗拉吧。
This tape is from the documentary TV program American High . A kid named Morgan is fighting with his parents because he wants to use the good car, the Corolla, and not the bad car, the Acclaim.
这段录音来自纪录片电视节目《美国高中》。一个叫摩根的孩子正在和父母吵架，因为他想开那辆好车——卡罗拉，而不是那辆破车——Acclaim。
If I wear my Tigger suit can I take the Corolla?
如果我穿上我的跳跳虎服装，我能开卡罗拉吗？
No, it's particularly if you're wearing your Tigger suit you can't take the Corolla.
不行，尤其是在你穿跳跳虎服装的时候，你绝对不能开卡罗拉。
Why?
为什么？
There is just something about the way this family argues that is deeply, deeply entertaining. They're out to amuse themselves, even when they're fighting.
这家人争吵的方式有一种非常非常引人入胜的地方。他们即使在吵架时，也总能自娱自乐。
How am I supposed to get women in that car?
我怎么能开着那辆车去泡妞呢？
You're not. That was one of the reasons I bought it. I tested it first and I didn't find any women when I was driving it.
你不用泡妞。这就是我买那辆车的原因之一。我试驾过，开它的时候我没遇到过任何女人。
You can't--
你不能——
I said this is the car for Morgan.
我说过，这辆车是给摩根开的。
You can't be like, hey baby, you wanna get in my love machine, baby?
你总不能说，嘿宝贝，想坐坐我的爱情机器吗，宝贝？
Got to get a homely car for you.
你就只配开这种土气的车。
One of the things that was fascinating about watching this TV show, American High , was watching the family dynamics. The other families that the producers filmed fought completely differently than this one did. Less humor, more strain. Now, of course, nobody in a family chooses the family dynamic. It just kind of happens. And when things go wrong in a family, it can feel like nobody had any choice about that either. You know, a kid does something that sets off a parent, who then does something that sets off the kid, and on and on and on.
观看《美国高中》这部电视节目最迷人的地方之一，就是观察其中的家庭动态。制片人拍摄的其他家庭和这一家的吵架方式完全不同。幽默感更少，紧张感更多。当然，没有人能选择自己的家庭动态。它就是会那样发生。当家庭出现问题时，感觉就像没人对此有选择权一样。你知道，孩子做的一件事会激怒父母，父母接着做的一件事又会激怒孩子，如此循环往复。
Well, today on our show, we bring you two stories that are sort of worst-case scenarios for any parent, both kind of incredible stories, because when you take apart how what happened happened, it's really hard to see how anybody could have prevented things from going bad.
嗯，今天在我们的节目中，我们要带给您两个故事，对任何父母来说，这都算是最糟糕的情况，它们都是那种不可思议的故事，因为当你拆解事情发生的经过时，你真的很难看出有人能阻止事情变糟。
Our first story is told by a mother and two of her four daughters. Her two oldest daughters, teenagers when the story begins. Though the mom remembers their baby years this way.
我们的第一个故事由一位母亲和她的四个女儿中的两个讲述。当故事开始时，她的两个大女儿还是十几岁。不过，这位母亲是这样回忆她们婴儿时期的。
When Amanda was born, I was 21 years old. All I wanted to do was care for her and that's what I did. It's funny, when I got pregnant with Stephanie, I was thinking, I'll never love anybody like I love Amanda. I could not imagine that my heart could grow large enough to accommodate another child because I loved Amanda with such an overwhelming sense of identity. She was me and I was her. I mean, we were so linked. And then, of course, when Stephanie was born, this astonishing thing happened, in that I fell in love with her too. And I was really, really close to those two. They were my-- there was no difference between them and me.
阿曼达出生时，我才21岁。我当时唯一想做的就是照顾她，我也确实这么做了。有趣的是，当我怀上斯蒂芬妮时，我在想，我永远不会像爱阿曼达那样爱任何人。我无法想象我的心能变得足够宽广去容纳另一个孩子，因为我爱阿曼达，那种认同感太强烈了。她就是我，我就是她。我的意思是，我们联系得太紧密了。然后，当然，当斯蒂芬妮出生时，一件令人惊讶的事情发生了，我同样爱上了她。我和那两个孩子真的非常亲密。她们是我的——她们和我之间没有任何区别。
My name is Debra Gwartney. We left Tucson the day I signed my divorce papers after a 13-year marriage. And I had thought about it for a long time and decided that it was really best for everyone involved if we moved away. The relationship had become volatile and it just wasn't going to be good for the girls or for me or for my ex-husband if we were all in the same town. Everybody I grew up around had that code of moving on and toughness. And I had a job offer in Eugene, Oregon, and I took it.
我叫黛布拉·格瓦特尼。我在结束了13年的婚姻并签下离婚协议的那天离开了图森。我考虑了很久，认为我们搬走对涉及到的每个人来说都是最好的。我们的关系变得不稳定，如果我们都留在同一个镇上，对女孩们、对我或者对我前夫来说都不会是好事。我成长过程中接触到的每个人都有那种“继续前进”和“坚韧不拔”的准则。我在俄勒冈州的尤金得到了一份工作机会，我就接受了。
My name is Stephanie. It was cold and wet. I didn't like it. And I didn't like the house we lived in. I didn't like the school I was going to. I don't know, I was pretty angry.
我叫斯蒂芬妮。那里又冷又湿。我不喜欢那里。我也不喜欢我们住的房子。我不喜欢我要去的学校。我不知道，我当时非常生气。
I'm Amanda. I hated the rain in Eugene. It was just dreary and cold all the time. It would settle in your bones. I still had this huge loyalty to my dad. And he was so depressed. I felt guilty that I was with my mom. I felt like I was disloyal, dishonest with my dad by being there with my mom. I think that's where the anger came from. You feel like they're trying to make you pick sides.
我是阿曼达。我讨厌尤金的雨。那里总是阴沉沉的，冷得透心凉。那种寒意仿佛刻在骨子里。我当时对我爸爸还有着巨大的忠诚感。而他非常抑郁。我和妈妈在一起让我感到内疚。我觉得通过和妈妈在一起，我对爸爸不忠诚，不诚实。我想愤怒就是从那里来的。你觉得他们在试图让你选边站。
It felt like we were abandoning him, abandoning my father. And I blamed that on my mom.
感觉就像我们在抛弃他，抛弃我的父亲。我把这怪罪于我妈妈。
Stephanie slept every night with a photograph of her dad under her pillow. There was a tremendous sense of guilt about leaving him in Arizona, and they couldn't understand why we couldn't go back. And I just kept thinking, well, if I could just do things the way I used to do it, we'd be OK. So I'd come home from work and make these elaborate meals and make sure that we had homemade muffins. And then on the weekends we'd drive to the coast to look at tide pools. And I'd just demand that we do these things together. And the older girls were stomping along bitterly and angrily. And they just wanted to be isolated, and I just thought, if I could un-isolate them as much as possible, we'd get through whatever this was.
斯蒂芬妮每天晚上睡觉时，枕头底下都放着她爸爸的照片。离开他在亚利桑那州，这让她们产生了一种巨大的负罪感，她们无法理解为什么我们不能回去。我当时一直想，如果我能像过去那样做事，我们就会好起来的。所以我下班回家后会准备这些精致的饭菜，确保我们有自制的松饼。周末，我们会开车去海岸看潮池。我只是要求我们一起做这些事情。而大一点的女孩们苦涩且愤怒地跺着脚。她们只想被孤立，而我只是想，如果我能尽可能地消除她们的孤立感，我们就能渡过这个难关。
When I first really started getting into the punk rock scene, I got into it purely for the angry, drunk, violent aspect of it. That's what really spoke to me at first.
当我第一次真正接触朋克摇滚时，我完全是被它那种愤怒、酗酒、暴力的方面所吸引。那是最初真正打动我的东西。
I guess it was 6th grade, yeah. I don't know, I just started hanging out with people that weren't necessarily motivated to be 12. I met people that were smoking pot and skipping school and stuff. And so both of us kind of bled into that culture.
我想那是在六年级，对。我不知道，我只是开始和那些不一定有动力去做个12岁孩子的人混在一起。我遇到了一些抽大麻、逃学之类的人。所以我们两个都慢慢陷入了那种文化。
I wore ripped-up stuff. And I had these plaid pants with zippers up the back that were skin tight, and big huge boots and angry spiky jewelry.
我穿撕破的衣服。我有一条紧身格纹裤，背后有拉链，还穿大头靴，戴着愤怒的尖刺首饰。
Then we cut our hair off.
然后我们把头发剪了。
I cut my hair into a mohawk.
我把头发剪成了莫霍克头。
And I had just dyed my hair pink. I dyed my hair pink. Amanda dyed her hair blue. Took my hair in my hand and took the scissors and chopped it off. It was just a scraggly pink mess of hair. Totally killed my mom.
我刚把头发染成了粉红色。我把头发染成了粉红色。阿曼达把头发染成了蓝色。我用手抓起头发，拿起剪刀把它剪了。那是一团乱糟糟的粉色头发。彻底把我妈气坏了。
She took away my Pearl Jam and my combat boots, and told me that I needed to start wearing happier clothes. Like, stop putting off the air of being so sad and angry and depressed. Like, she thought it was the music I was listening to.
她没收了我的珍珠果酱乐队的磁带和战斗靴，告诉我需要开始穿一些更开心的衣服。比如，停止散发那种悲伤、愤怒和抑郁的气息。她以为是我听的音乐造成的。
I made an immature assumption that we were going to come to Eugene and we were going to be in this together. Whatever the barriers were to happiness or peace, the five of us were going to confront those together and get through it. And when the girls first started acting out, I was really astonished that they would do that to this effort of making a new life. They weren't going according to plan, the plan that I had in my own head about how we were going to create this new life.
我做了一个不成熟的假设，认为我们会来到尤金，我们会齐心协力。无论幸福或平静的障碍是什么，我们五个人都会一起面对并渡过难关。当女孩们第一次开始表现出反叛时，我真的很震惊，她们竟然会那样对待我为了创造新生活所做的努力。她们没有按照计划行事，那个在我脑海中关于我们如何创造新生活的计划。
I think that my mom's protectiveness and her need to hold things together, just that frantic need to hold things together, kind of pushed Amanda and I away. But I think that she wanted things to work so badly that any move that we made that was not what she had had in mind, the tension rose so easily.
我想我妈妈的保护欲以及她想要稳住一切的需要，那种想要稳住一切的疯狂需求，反而把我和阿曼达推开了。但我觉得她太想让事情顺利进行了，以至于我们做出的任何不符合她预期的举动，都会让紧张气氛轻易升级。
And I remember telling them, when times got tough during wars and during depressions in this country, the kids rally. They stick with it and help the family get through the toughness. And they would look at me like, uh, [BLEEP] that. I mean, I'm sure they said that right to my face.
我记得我告诉过她们，当这个国家在战争和萧条时期变得艰难时，孩子们会团结起来。他们会坚持下去，帮助家庭度过难关。她们看着我，就像在说，去你的。我的意思是，我相信她们就是当面这么说的。
We would come to school high, just run around, and smoke in the bathrooms, and chase people around with sporks. That was one of our favorite things. Do you know what a spork is? It's a spoon-fork. We would pretend like everybody was aliens. It was our, like, honing in device. It was crazy.
我们会吸了毒去学校，到处乱跑，在厕所里抽烟，拿着叉勺追赶别人。那是我们最喜欢做的事情之一。你知道什么是叉勺吗？就是叉子和勺子的合体。我们会假装每个人都是外星人。那是我们，就像，我们的锁定装置。太疯狂了。
And we would stand at one end of the hall and crouch down and-- we would call it the rampage. In the commons, all the soccer girls, all the really preppy kids would hang out. And we'd put our arms in front of our head and run through the crowd, knocking people over.
我们会站在走廊的一头，蹲下——我们称之为“横冲直撞”。在公共区域，所有的足球女孩，所有那些势利的预科生都会待在那里。我们会把手臂放在头前，冲进人群，把人撞倒。
And then Amanda-- oh, Amanda-- she lit the bathroom on fire, and all the trash in the trash cans. She was just playing. And these two girls walk in-- super rich girls-- and went to the principal. And Amanda got arrested. She got charged with arson and got suspended from school. And that's when I really started despising the upper class, girls that played soccer, rode horses, got fake tans. So that's when I really started hating those kind of people.
然后阿曼达——噢，阿曼达——她把厕所点着了，还有垃圾桶里的所有垃圾。她只是在玩。然后这两个女孩走进来——超级富有的女孩——去报告了校长。阿曼达被逮捕了。她被指控纵火并被学校停课。也就是从那时起，我开始鄙视上层阶级，那些踢足球、骑马、喷美黑喷雾的女孩。所以也就是从那时起，我开始讨厌那种人。
I got a call from their school saying that they hadn't been in school for at least a week. And I thought, well, where are they? I'm dropping them off at the front door of the school. Where are they going? So I raced home to try to find them. And they were there. And they said they just didn't feel like going to school. They were sick of school. There was no reason to go. And I said, well, where are you going? And they said they were just hanging around downtown. And I -- this is just untenable. We can't live this way. I mean, I can't have my two older daughters just wandering and then coming home at night for dinner like nothing-- like this is normal or something. If you want to live here with me, you have to go to school.
我接到学校打来的电话，说她们至少有一周没来上学了。我想，好吧，她们去哪了？我把她们送到学校门口的。她们去哪了？所以我飞车回家想找她们。她们就在那。她们说只是不想去上学了。她们厌倦了学校。没有理由去上学。我说，好吧，你们去哪了？她们说只是在市中心闲逛。我——这简直无法维持。我们不能这样生活。我的意思是，我不能让我的两个大女儿到处流浪，然后晚上回来吃晚饭，好像什么都没发生——好像这是正常的一样。如果你想和我住在一起，你就必须去上学。
About an hour later, they went into the bathroom and they were getting all dolled up. And Amanda was dying Stephanie's hair this bright color of pink with this Manic Panic dye. And I could see that they were getting ready to go, and putting all this tons of makeup on, big black streaks around their eyes, and spiking up their hair. And I opened the door and I said you can't go out. Amanda just pushed the door closed in my face. And they locked the door and they were in there just turning the music up really loud and laughing and shouting at each other.
大约一小时后，她们进了洗手间，开始打扮自己。阿曼达用这种Manic Panic染发剂把斯蒂芬妮的头发染成了亮粉色。我能看出她们准备要出门了，抹了厚厚的妆，眼睛周围画着巨大的黑色条纹，头发竖了起来。我打开门说你们不能出去。阿曼达直接把门在我脸上关上了。她们锁上门，在里面把音乐开得很大，大声笑着喊着。
I was so determined not to let them go out the door that night. So I went to the front door of the house and I just stood there. And they came out and they both had backpacks on. They walked over and said, get out of the way. And I said no. I was blocking the door. I was keeping-- my legs were apart and my arms were out. And I said, I'm not going to let you go out. You can't go. And I remember Amanda saying, Mom, we don't want to hurt you. By that time, both of the little girls were on the periphery and shouting at all of us to stop this. They pushed me aside and they ran out. And as they pushed me, I tripped over a chair and fell.
我那天晚上一定要拦住她们，不让她们出门。所以我走到家里的前门，就站在那里。她们出来时都背着背包。她们走过来，说，让开。我说不。我挡着门。我保持着——双腿叉开，双臂张开。我说，我不会让你们出去的。你们不能走。我记得阿曼达说，妈妈，我们不想伤害你。到那时，两个小女孩都在旁边大喊大叫，让所有人都停下来。她们把我推开，跑了出去。在我推我的那一刻，我被一把椅子绊倒了。
I drove around until about 4:30 in the morning and never did find them. And we didn't see them again for eight days.
我开车兜了一圈直到凌晨4点半，一直没找到她们。之后八天我们就没再见到她们。
It was just a rough night, drinking 40s of malt liquor and smoking pot. And it just was a hard night for both of us.
那真是一个糟糕的夜晚，喝着40盎司的麦芽酒，抽着大麻。对我们俩来说都是艰难的一夜。
Me and Stephanie started sleeping in abandoned parking shelters. And we would find houses that weren't lived in and sleep in their backyard. And it was freezing cold too, and we only had these little blankets.
我和斯蒂芬妮开始睡在废弃的停车场棚子里。我们会找没人住的房子，睡在它们的后院。而且天气冷得要命，我们只有这些小毯子。
That first time they left, that's when I kind of entered the world that I never knew existed. It's not against the law to run away from home in Oregon. The truancy laws are also gone. If your child is missing from school for an extended period of time, all they do is basically drop that child from the rolls. No help from the police, no help from the schools. So I started looking into social service agencies. And they're really set up to help the child. But there's really no place for a parent to go and say, my child has run away. What can you do to help me get them back?
她们第一次离开时，我就进入了一个我从未知道存在过的世界。在俄勒冈州，离家出走并不违法。逃学法也不存在了。如果你的孩子长时间不来上学，学校基本上就是把这个孩子从名单上除名。没有警察的帮助，没有学校的帮助。所以我开始寻找社会服务机构。它们确实是为帮助孩子而设立的。但对于一个父母来说，真的没有地方可以去说，我的孩子离家出走了。你们能帮我把她们找回来吗？
I went to Amanda's counselor for help. And he suggested that I look into a therapy program where they would take the girls into the woods for several weeks and get them cleaned up off of drugs. And they suggested a person who specializes in going into the underground, the subculture of kids, and finding kids so they can put them in a group and get them out into the woods. So it really came down to finding a stranger and paying him $200 a day to seek them out. It was terrifying to get involved with someone like that, former cop, a former LA cop. I gave him a map of downtown Eugene and where I thought they liked to hang out. They at that time were very fond of the IHOP.
我去找阿曼达的心理顾问寻求帮助。他建议我了解一个治疗项目，他们会把女孩们带到树林里几周，帮她们戒掉毒品。他推荐了一个专门研究进入地下世界、青少年亚文化的人，去寻找这些孩子，把她们集中起来带到树林里。所以这真的归结为找一个陌生人，每天付他200美元去寻找她们。和这样的人打交道太可怕了，一个前警察，一个前洛杉矶警察。我给了他一张尤金市中心的地图，标出了我认为她们喜欢去的地方。她们那时非常喜欢去IHOP餐馆。
One day, me and Stephanie had woken up and we were walking downtown, and some guy comes up to us and points at me and goes, you're Stephanie? And points at Stephanie and goes, you're Amanda? We shake our heads, no, we're not. He's like, no, I know you guys are. He was like-- told us he was a private investigator hired to find us and the police were going to pick us up, and that he was going to take us to a safe place where we could eat.
有一天，我和斯蒂芬妮刚醒，正走在市中心，有个家伙走过来指着我问，你是斯蒂芬妮？又指着斯蒂芬妮问，你是阿曼达？我们摇头说，不，我们不是。他说，不，我知道你们是。他告诉我们，他是雇来找我们的私家侦探，警察要把我们抓走，他要把我们带到一个安全的地方，我们可以吃饭。
And he was a horrible man. He was just a bad man, with his son. They got us in their car and it was weird. And they drove and drove and we drove to Sisters, Oregon. And then it got really scary. And they strip-searched us and put us in crazy clothes. And they took Amanda. And I stayed there for a week with all these other girls, just milling around, wanting a cigarette more than anything in the world. It was just such a weird, surreal situation, really horrible.
他是个可怕的人。他是个坏蛋，和他儿子一起。他们把我们拉进车里，感觉很怪。我们开了又开，开车去了俄勒冈州的塞斯特斯。然后事情变得真的很吓人。他们对我们进行了搜身，换上了奇怪的衣服。他们带走了阿曼达。我在那儿和别的女孩待了一周，四处徘徊，比世界上任何东西都更想要一支香烟。这真是一个怪异、超现实的情况，真的很可怕。
I drove to Albany, Oregon on a Saturday. And then the people in Sisters transported Amanda there first. And we met in this room and she was a ball of fury. And we were in this very cold, impersonal room with 10 sets of parents and their angry teenagers. I guess I was still, at that point, thinking, if I could just make the right move, if I could just find the right puzzle pieces, then this is all going to fall back in place again. I guess I was still in that illusion that there is a cure here, and if I could just find it, we'll be OK.
周六我开车去了俄勒冈州的奥尔巴尼。塞斯特斯那边的人先把阿曼达送到了那里。我们在一个房间里见面，她简直是一团怒火。我们在一个非常寒冷、冷冰冰的房间里，里面有10对父母和他们愤怒的青少年。我想我当时还在想，如果我能走对一步，如果我能找到正确的拼图块，那么这一切都会恢复原状。我想我仍然沉浸在“这里有治愈方法”的错觉中，如果我能找到它，我们会好起来的。
And they explained to the kids that they will have a small packet of lentils and rice and a few vegetables and a pan, and that they'll be responsible for building their own fire, and that they would teach them how to build a snow shelter to try to stay warm. And so they locked them in this van. And here we were, all these parents standing in this driveway. And they just backed out and drove away. A week later I did the same thing with Stephanie.
他们向孩子们解释说，她们会得到一小袋扁豆、大米和一些蔬菜以及一个平底锅，她们必须负责自己生火，他们会教她们如何建造雪洞以保持温暖。然后他们把她们锁进了一辆面包车里。我们就这样，所有家长都站在车道上。他们只是倒车离开了。一周后，我带着斯蒂芬妮也做了同样的事。
We were in the Cascades and there was about 11 feet of snow on the ground and we were in this huge blizzard. They had a wall tent with a wood stove in it. We'd met another group there. And I didn't know, but it was Stephanie's group.
我们在喀斯喀特山脉，地面上有大约11英尺厚的积雪，我们陷入了一场巨大的暴风雪。他们有一个带木炉的墙壁帐篷。我们在那儿遇到了另一群人。我不知道，但那是斯蒂芬妮那一组。
So I walked past Amanda. And I didn't see her because it was in the dark. I couldn't tell which one was her, but I knew I was walking past her. And I was singing Blondie or something. I don't remember, something she would recognize. She knew I was there. I sang all night, sang to her.
我走过阿曼达身边。我没看见她，因为天很黑。我认不出哪个是她，但我知道我正走过她身边。我在唱Blondie乐队的歌或者是别的什么。我不记得了，她能认出来的歌。她知道我在那儿。我唱了一整晚，唱给她听。
They let me talk to her for five minutes. We were just looking at each other's hands and I still had fingernail polish on. She said, how'd you keep your fingernail polish on that long? And I was like, I don't know. I just wear gloves all the time. And we were just looking at each other, just faces and hands, and then got ripped apart again. That was the only time we got to see each other for about six months.
他们让我和她说了五分钟话。我们只是看着彼此的手，我的指甲油还没掉。她说，你怎么把指甲油保持得这么久？我说，我不知道。我只是总戴着手套。我们只是看着彼此的脸和手，然后又被强行分开了。那是我们在大约六个月里唯一一次见面。
After the wilderness trip, Amanda went to live with a family in eastern Oregon, where she worked on their ranch. And Stephanie was living with our friends in Montana. And the thought that-- I mean, my whole image of myself was as a mother. And the thought that I had failed so much that my daughter was now called a foster child. And when we would go there, I felt so tiny, tiny and sloppy. I just felt like this-- you know, like the welfare mothers you see in line buying candy bars with their welfare checks and everybody's clicking their tongues and judging them. I felt like that. I felt like such a failure.
荒野之旅后，阿曼达去了一个俄勒冈州东部的家庭寄住，她在他们的牧场工作。斯蒂芬妮住在我们蒙大拿州的朋友那里。那个想法——我的意思是，我整个人生形象都是作为一名母亲。我想到我失败得如此彻底，以至于我的女儿现在被称为寄养儿童。当我们去那里时，我觉得自己很渺小、邋遢。我感觉就像——你知道，就像你在福利领取队伍里看到的那些用救济券买糖果棒的母亲，每个人都在啧啧称奇、评头论足。我感觉就像那样。我感觉自己太失败了。
When Amanda was in foster care, I saw her quite often and I thought a lot had been healed between us. She was really dependent on me, so I thought we were really off on a good footing for that next fall. We started the year off and it was just-- it was a fiasco. They didn't want to go back to school. It just wasn't working. It was a continual battle with them. And they just wanted to be out partying with their friends. I just couldn't have these street kids that came home now and then to eat.
当阿曼达在寄养家庭时，我经常去看她，我以为我们之间的很多伤痕都愈合了。她真的很依赖我，所以我以为我们为那个秋天打下了很好的基础。我们开始新的一年，结果却是——那是一场惨败。她们不想回学校。根本行不通。和她们之间的战斗在持续。她们只想出去和朋友们聚会。我不能接受这些偶尔回家吃顿饭的街头流浪儿。
It was basically a mantra. If you don't do what I say, you're not going to live here. If you don't do what I say, you're not going to live here. And that would just ring in my head over and over. And that just planted a little seed, like, fine. I'm not going to live here.
这基本上成了一句咒语。如果你不听我的，你就别住在这儿。如果你不听我的，你就别住在这儿。那句话会在我脑海里反复回响。这只是种下了一颗小种子，心想，行。我不住了。
And the girls walked in the house. And I was outside doing some things. And they came out with these huge backpacks and bed rolls. And you know, I just didn't even have the strength to say, stop.
女孩们走进房子。我当时在外面做些事情。她们带着巨大的背包和睡袋出来了。你知道，我甚至没有力气说，停下。
I had my backpack and a pair of shoes tied onto my backpack. She said, where are you guys going? Out to coffee. Why do you need two pairs of shoes to go out to coffee? That's the last thing she said.
我背着背包，背包上还系着一双鞋。她说，你们要去哪？出去喝咖啡。去喝咖啡为什么要带两双鞋？那是她说的最后一句话。
And they walked down the street and that was it.
她们沿着街道走下去，就这样了。
It was weird. It was fun, exciting, adventurous, new. Lots of good stories. Every day was a story, like a book. Going by Shasta, Mount Shasta, in a box car, and just seeing things that not many people get to see. It was like nothing else I've ever done. There was a lot of pain involved, but at the same time, it was like every moment I was actually living in the moment and I was there. I haven't really felt that since.
那感觉很奇怪。很有趣、令人兴奋、充满冒险，一切都是新的。有很多好故事。每一天都是一个故事，像一本书。搭乘货车经过沙斯塔山，看到很多人们看不到的东西。那是我做过的任何事都无法比拟的。过程中有很多痛苦，但同时，就像每一刻我都真切地活在当下。自那以后我再也没这种感觉了。
In the next couple of months, every now and then Amanda would call-- never Stephanie-- and either leave a message or she'd get me on the phone and say, we're alive, we're OK. But she would never tell me where they were. And I would say, come home. You need to come home. We need to work this out. She'd just hang up.
在接下来的几个月里，阿曼达偶尔会打电话——从不是斯蒂芬妮——要么留个言，要么在电话里跟我说，我们还活着，我们没事。但她从不告诉我她们在哪里。我会说，回家吧。你们需要回家。我们需要解决这个问题。她就会挂断电话。
When we were in San Francisco, that was the crazy times. Me and Amanda, that's when we first started doing dope. But one night, I had wandered off. I was totally screwed up and out of my head. Alcohol, cocaine, marijuana, ecstasy, pills, psychotropic pills, all that stuff, 40s all day on the block. So I had my dog in my hand and I wandered off up the street, and just was wandering around, totally cracked out, like, walking around in the Tenderloin at 11:00 at night.
在旧金山的时候，那是疯狂的时期。我和阿曼达，就在那时我们开始吸毒。但有一天晚上，我走散了。我完全搞砸了，神志不清。酒精、可卡因、大麻、摇头丸、药片，精神类药物，所有那些东西，整天在街区喝40盎司麦芽酒。我手里牵着狗，沿着街道漫无目的地走，完全疯了，就像晚上11点走在田德隆区一样。
At night in San Francisco, the crackheads come out with all this stuff they've gathered during they day, because crackheads gather things. They're like pigeons. They're attracted to the shiny metal. A lot of times, they roll out pieces of carpet and lay all the things they've found out: lamps and spoons and hub caps and prosthetic pieces of people, I've seen, just lost treasures. At night, it's like the crackhead fair. There's people with their shopping carts laying out all the stuff they found.
在旧金山的夜晚，瘾君子们会带着他们白天收集的所有东西出来，因为瘾君子会收集各种东西。他们就像鸽子。他们被闪闪发光的金属吸引。很多时候，他们会铺开地毯，把找到的所有东西展示出来：灯、勺子、轮毂盖，我甚至见过人的假肢，全是丢失的宝藏。晚上，那就像瘾君子的集市。到处都是推着购物车的人，展示他们捡到的东西。
When you're high on drugs, like I was that night, I thought I was at a little market place. And so I was walking along and this one crackhead had all this stuff, a carpet laid out with all this stuff. And I picked up a candle. And he came out of nowhere, just like a banshee out of hell, just screaming towards me. And I don't know, in the struggle I got cut on my arm. I was just kind of dumbfounded. I was like, what just happened? So I just left. And then I remember walking and just being covered with blood. And I walked up to Sixth and Market, and all my friends are sitting there. And I walk up and my mouth is open and there's blood everywhere. And my friend cleaned it up for me.
当你像那天晚上那样吸毒后，我觉得自己是在一个小集市里。所以我走着，有个瘾君子有一大堆东西，铺着地毯。我捡起一根蜡烛。他不知从哪冒出来，就像地狱里的女妖，尖叫着冲向我。我不知道，在挣扎中我的胳膊被划伤了。我当时有点目瞪口呆。我想，刚才发生了什么？所以我只是离开了。然后我记得走着走着，身上全是血。我走到第六街和市场街，我所有的朋友都坐在那儿。我走过去，嘴张着，到处都是血。我的朋友帮我清理了。
It felt like there was almost protection around us, or a bubble, just something protecting Amanda and I, something special about our journey through this dark place. We just glided through it and remained untouched.
感觉仿佛我们周围有一种保护，或者说一个泡泡，有什么东西在保护着我和阿曼达，我们穿过这个黑暗之地的旅程有些特别。我们只是滑行穿过，毫发无损。
She and I have such a different way of looking at that time. She was so happy and she was making her part in this community. And I feel used and-- I don't know. My idea of the whole thing was to put my life on my back and just go, and stop looking back, stop feeling guilty, stop all these raging emotions, just keep going, keep moving. I had saved about $1,500. And I had an ATM card. And so we would panhandle and we would live off what I had, until I got a heroin habit, and then it went pretty fast.
她和我对那段时间的看法截然不同。她当时很开心，她在那个社区里找到了自己的位置。而我感觉被利用了——我不知道。我对整件事的想法就是把生活背在背上，继续前进，不再回头，不再感到内疚，不再有那些狂暴的情绪，只是继续走，不停地移动。我攒了大约1500美元。我有一张ATM卡。所以我们会乞讨，靠我手里的钱过活，直到我染上了海洛因瘾，然后一切很快就完了。
So we made it to Tucson. And we decided to get some heroin. And so we went down to this drainage tunnel, and Amanda took her shot of dope and as I was about to-- as I was about to-- I had drawn up my blood and I was about to put it all back into my arm, I looked over at Amanda and I said, you're looking kind of gray, Amanda. And she says, oh, I feel fine. She's really, really hammered. And the boy that was next to us said, oh, she's fine, and so I pushed all the heroin into my arm.
所以我们到了图森。我们决定弄点海洛因。于是我们去了这个排水隧道，阿曼达给自己注射了毒品，当我正要——当我正要——我已经抽出了血，正要把它推回静脉时，我看着阿曼达说，阿曼达，你的脸色看起来有点发灰。她说，哦，我感觉很好。她当时已经HIGH得不行了。旁边那个男孩说，哦，她没事的，于是我把海洛因全部推进了静脉。
And right then, Amanda fell over. She had done too much and it was not a good batch, because I couldn't-- could barely walk. I was crawling over to her, and this was the first time I've ever done CPR. I'm sure I broke some of her ribs. And I couldn't get her to breathe. Her heart would beat for little bit and then stop and start again. And she would-- she took like two breaths the whole day. And I don't know how she did it. I just kept telling people, call a [BLEEP] ambulance. Everybody wouldn't. They said, no, we're just going to wait for a little while longer. We could all get in big trouble for this. I was like, I don't give a [BLEEP]. I'll got to jail for the rest of my life. Get me an ambulance.
就在那一瞬间，阿曼达倒下了。她用得太多了，而且那批货质量不好，因为我当时——几乎无法走路。我爬向她，这是我第一次做心肺复苏。我敢肯定我弄断了她几根肋骨。我无法让她呼吸。她的心跳动了一会儿然后停止，又重新开始。她那天只呼吸了两次。我不知道她是怎么做到的。我只是不停地对人们说，叫救护车。大家都不肯。他们说，不，我们再等一会儿。我们都会因为这事惹大麻烦的。我说，我才不管那么多。我哪怕下半辈子都在监狱里度过。给我叫辆救护车。
And then this guy put her on his back and he was dragging her in her shoes. Like, the next day, you could see where her shoes were all worn down. There was all these little Mexican kids chasing after him, going what's wrong with her? What's wrong with her? And we got her as fast as we could to this house, some fat guy's apartment. He was watching The Simpsons. Right as the ambulance pulled up, Amanda lifted her head up by herself. We got to the hospital. And so we're sitting there and a cop comes in. He handcuffs us both to the bed.
然后有个家伙把她背在背上，拖着她走，她的鞋都磨坏了。第二天，你能看到她的鞋底磨损得有多严重。周围有一群墨西哥小孩追着他问，她怎么了？她怎么了？我们尽可能快地把她送到一间房子里，一个胖子的公寓。他当时正在看《辛普森一家》。就在救护车停下的那一刻，阿曼达自己抬起了头。我们到了医院。我们坐在那儿，一个警察进来了。他把我们俩都铐在了病床上。
And the phone rang. And it was a hospital in Tucson, calling to tell me that Amanda had been found. And it was the first time I had any clue that she was using heroin. And that was really a lot to take all at once. She was in a hospital. They'd had to restart her heart, and she was a heroin addict.
电话响了。是图森的一家医院，打来告诉我阿曼达找到了。这是我第一次知道她在使用海洛因。那简直让人难以承受。她在医院里。他们不得不重启她的心脏，而她是一名海洛因成瘾者。
The policeman took us in his car down to this halfway house. We booked as soon as he left. Two days later, the police stopped us for loitering and ran our names. I spouted out my false identity and Amanda gave her real name. And I turned and looked at her, shocked.
警察把我们带进他的车里，送到了一个半途之家。他一走，我们就跑了。两天后，警察因为流浪罪拦住我们并查了我们的身份。我脱口而出假身份，而阿曼达说了真名。我转过头震惊地看着她。
Whenever we talk about it, it always comes back to, well, why did you give your real name to the cop, Amanda? It's your fault. Can you understand why I gave my real name to the cop, Stephanie? I just want her understand it, that it was the only thing I could have done in that situation. And maybe I wasn't-- maybe I was tired. I had just died.
每当我们谈起这件事，总是回到，好吧，阿曼达，你为什么要跟警察说真名？是你的错。斯蒂芬妮，你能理解我为什么要跟警察说真名吗？我只是想让她明白，在那种情况下，那是唯一能做的事。也许我不是——也许我太累了。我刚才经历了一次死亡。
They ran our names and Amanda's came up dirty, as you would say. And they took her backpack, put it in their trunk. I gave her a big hug and kiss and I said, I'll see you soon. And that was the last time I saw her for a year. And we were torn apart. And we never really healed that wound.
他们查了我们的名字，阿曼达的记录显示有问题。他们拿走了她的背包，放进后备箱。我给她一个大大的拥抱和亲吻，说，我会很快见到你的。那是我最后一次见到她，持续了一年。我们被分开了。我们从来没有真正愈合那个伤口。
She went and did it alone. I was so mad that she was still doing it and I was stuck. I was her sister.
她独自去做这件事了。我很生气，她还在吸而我却被困住了。我是她的姐妹。
I don't know, it was like a journey we had to complete or something and it felt like it was cut short. I had to keep going, for some reason. It was like some kind of Homer's Odyssey. We had to make it to the end, whatever that end was, which we didn't really know. I left Tucson. I hopped a train to Texas. So we'd go through Arizona, go through Benson and out to the border of New Mexico. And all of a sudden, out of nowhere, you're in a town.
我不知道，那就像我们必须完成的一段旅程，而且感觉被中途切断了。因为某种原因，我必须继续前行。这就像荷马的《奥德赛》。我们必须走到终点，不管那个终点是什么，我们其实并不知道。我离开了图森。我搭上一辆去德州的火车。我们穿过亚利桑那州，经过本森，来到新墨西哥州的边界。突然间，不知从哪冒出来一个城镇。
And Stephanie was 14 years old. Where was she? I went to San Francisco because Amanda thought she was maybe there. And she thought she was perhaps in the Tenderloin district, because they had found a community there. And this friend of ours went with me. And that is a really horrible area. There are all these majestic looking buildings with homeless people everywhere, and weird piles of used clothes all over, that I guess people just dump there and let people look through. Every park bench, every fountain, ledge, every step up to the library had another little blanket tent. It was like walking through a campground of some sort. We were looking, trying to look at faces to see if we could see her.
当时斯蒂芬妮才14岁。她在哪？我去旧金山是因为阿曼达觉得她可能在那儿。她认为她可能在田德隆区，因为她们在那里找到了一个社区。我们的一个朋友陪我去了。那真是一个糟糕的地方。到处都是宏伟的建筑，住着无家可归的人，到处都是奇怪的旧衣服堆，我想人们只是把它们扔在那儿，让别人去翻找。每个公园长椅、每个喷泉、每个台阶、每级通往图书馆的楼梯上都有另一个简陋的毯子帐篷。这就像穿过一个某种营地。我们在寻找，试图盯着每张脸看能不能认出她来。
She was looking for me when I was in Texas. I wasn't anywhere near San Francisco at the time. I understand why she went there to look for me, or why she went anywhere. It's a really sad story that she has to tell. And I feel incredibly guilty that I put her through that, and that she had to go to the places where I'd been and had to see that. So I was waitressing at a pizza place for about 50 hours a week, and got really good at it. Great tips. Walk out of there with $100 sometimes at night.
我在德州时她在找我。当时我离旧金山远着呢。我理解她为什么去那里找我，或者她为什么去任何地方。她讲述的故事真的很悲伤。我对自己让她经历这一切，让她不得不去我去过的地方、看到那些东西感到无比内疚。所以我每周在一家披萨店当50个小时的服务员，并且做得很好。小费很多。有时晚上出来能带走100美元。
Of course, I was coming out of my addiction. I was praying a lot. So then I started going to the Catholic church. It was a block away from my house. Saint Austin's Church. And I used to sneak my dog in. I would put him in my shirt, my jacket. And I would put holy water on his face and holy water on me. And we'd sneak into the back and it was this huge old church and we would always go to the Mother Mary. So we used to go hang out there for hours and just sit and be quiet and pray, light candles for my family.
当然，我正在摆脱毒瘾。我做了很多祈祷。于是我开始去天主教堂。离我家只有一街之隔。圣奥斯汀教堂。我总是把狗偷偷带进去。我会把它放进我的衬衫、外套里。我会给它的脸上抹圣水，给自己抹上圣水。我们偷偷溜进后面，那是一个巨大的老教堂，我们总是去圣母玛利亚雕像那儿。所以我们常在那儿一待就是几个小时，安静地坐着祈祷，为我的家人点燃蜡烛。
So Christmas Eve came and we did all of our usual traditional things, which was very hollow and cold. We all were sitting in the living room, kind of staring at each other on Christmas Eve, not knowing what to do. And I said, well, why don't we all write Stephanie a letter? And I thought, corny and a little contrived, even. But it just came out of nowhere. So, to my utter amazement, Amanda was into that. She really wanted to do it. So we each took a couple pieces of paper and went to a different place in the house and wrote. And Amanda wrote for over an hour. She just wrote and wrote and wrote.
平安夜到了，我们照常做了一切传统仪式，但这感觉非常空洞和冰冷。平安夜我们都坐在客厅里，盯着对方，不知道该做什么。我说，不如我们每个人给斯蒂芬妮写封信吧？我觉得这很俗气，甚至有点做作。但它就是突然冒了出来。让我大为惊讶的是，阿曼达竟然同意了。她真的想这么做。所以我们每人拿了几张纸，走到房子不同的角落写了起来。阿曼达写了一个多小时。她不停地写啊写。
Yeah. I just asked her a lot of questions. Why are you doing this? What are you trying to accomplish at this point? You're hurting us all so bad. Please, let's try to work this out. Please call. Please tell us you're alive. Please be alive.
对，我只是问了她很多问题。你为什么要这么做？你现在想达到什么目的？你把我们每个人都伤得这么深。拜托，让我们试着解决它吧。请打电话。请告诉我们你还活着。请一定要活着。
And finally, Amanda came in with her pieces of paper that she'd written. And we all folded our notes up to Stephanie. And we took a pan, just a pan from under the stove, outside. It was a very cold night. And we stood in our driveway and we each put our letter to Stephanie in the pan and we lit it on fire, lit them on fire.
最后，阿曼达拿着她写的几张纸走了进来。我们每人都把写给斯蒂芬妮的信折叠起来。我们拿了一个平底锅，从炉子底下拿出来，走到外面。那是一个非常寒冷的夜晚。我们站在车道上，每人都把写给斯蒂芬妮的信放进锅里，点燃了它们。
And then we said prayers that she would call. I mean, I got a little taste of what my mom went through in those nine months where Stephanie didn't call us. I've never been so completely sad and just ruined. I mean, Stephanie wasn't even my child. She was just my sister and my best friend. And I couldn't sleep at night. I was just so sad that she was gone and I mourned her every day.
然后我们祈祷她能打电话回来。我的意思是，我稍微体会到了妈妈在那九个月里经历了什么，那时斯蒂芬妮没打电话给我们。我从来没有如此彻底地悲伤和毁掉。我的意思是，斯蒂芬妮甚至不是我的孩子。她只是我的妹妹和最好的朋友。我晚上无法入睡。我只是为她离开而感到悲伤，每天都在为她哀悼。
And we just stood there while they burned and the smoke went off. It's really amazing to me that we all survived this. There's just so many ways that somebody could have slipped away. Stephanie was 14 years old, and she got herself down to Texas and got a job and lived in an apartment and paid bills. I did not rescue her from that life. She rescued herself. And I think she'd very much like me to recognize that. And intellectually, I can. But when she's in the same room with me, and we're talking about this, I get so hurt.
我们就站在那儿看着它们燃烧，烟雾飘散。令我惊奇的是，我们竟然都活了下来。有人可能会滑向堕落的途径实在太多了。斯蒂芬妮才14岁，她自己跑到了德州，找了份工作，租了间公寓，付账单。我并没有从那种生活中拯救她。是她自己救了自己。我想她非常希望我能承认这一点。在理智上，我可以承认。但当她和我待在同一个房间里谈论这件事时，我感到很受伤。
I think she still rolls her eyes and feels hurt by me saying that this experience had some value. It's my life experience and it's important to me. And I just hope that someday she can acknowledge that.
我觉得她依然翻着白眼，对我声称这段经历有一些价值感到受伤。这是我的人生经历，它对我来说很重要。我只是希望有一天她能承认这一点。
Things aren't easy with either of the girls yet. They're so much better. And I can so freely say, I love you. And they say, I love you, Mom. And the words are so real. And I'm incredibly proud of both of them.
两个女孩的情况现在还没到容易的地步。她们好多了。我可以如此自然地说，我爱你。她们说，妈妈，我爱你。那些词语如此真实。我为她们两个感到无比自豪。
We are evolving and building a relationship now that's a lot stronger. We still don't really know each other very well, but--
我们正在演变，现在建立的关系比过去强大得多。我们仍然不了解彼此，但是——
It feels like our situation's changed, especially this year. She listens to me. She gives me advice. We're friends. She's my mom. I have a mom.
感觉我们的情况变了，尤其是今年。她听我的。她给我建议。我们是朋友。她是我的妈妈。我有妈妈了。
That story was produced by Sandy Tolan of Homelands Productions, in collaboration with Debra Gwartney, with her daughters Stephanie and Amanda. Debra has just come out with a book about her experience, called Live Through This , which had been featured in Salon and People magazine and reviewed all over the place. Stephanie is now in college in Massachusetts. Amanda has finished college and she lives in Oregon with her husband and two small children.
那个故事由Homelands Productions的桑迪·托兰制作，黛布拉·格瓦特尼和她的女儿斯蒂芬妮、阿曼达协作完成。黛布拉刚刚出版了一本关于她经历的书，叫《活下来》，它在《沙龙》杂志和《人物》杂志上被专题报道，受到各方好评。斯蒂芬妮现在在马萨诸塞州上大学。阿曼达大学毕业，和丈夫及两个年幼的孩子住在俄勒冈州。
Coming up, sounds like an ordinary school day, until the end. That's on Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，听起来是平常的一天，直到结尾。那是芝加哥公共电台和国际公共广播电台的节目，节目继续进行。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show we bring you two stories that I think anybody would consider parents' worst-case scenarios. Our first story was about girls who ran away. This next story is about someone, a teenager, who did something to himself that I think most people would find unthinkable. And he wasn't a loner. He had friends. His mom was a teacher, interested in his life. He wrote an account of what happened on that day, when he did what he did. A warning that some of the moments in this story are not appropriate for small children.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天在我们的节目中，我们要带给您两个我想任何人都认为是最糟糕的父母情境的故事。第一个故事是关于离家出走的女孩。下一个故事是关于一个人，一个青少年，对自己做了一件我想大多数人都会觉得不可思议的事。他不是一个孤独的人。他有朋友。他妈妈是个老师，关心他的生活。他写了一份关于那天发生的事情的记录，当他做了他所做的事的时候。提醒一下，这个故事中的一些时刻不适合年幼的孩子。
Monday, February 4, 1991. Falls Church, Virginia.
1991年2月4日，星期一。弗吉尼亚州福尔斯彻奇。
I'm awake, listening to the radio, and mom is yelling at me to wake up and get out of bed. I don't want to get out of bed. Maybe I should play sick. But I've done that too many times this year already. The bathroom is right next to my bed, so I don't have to put on a robe or anything. I just go in and lock the door behind me. And then the door that leads to the hallway, and then the one that separates the shower and toilet from the sink. It's weird that this bathroom has three locking doors, but I like it. If I ever have to hide from anyone, like a burglar or something, or really just want to be by myself, I can come in here and lock all the doors.
我醒了，听着收音机，妈妈正在大喊大叫让我起床。我不想起床。也许我该装病。但我今年已经这么干太多次了。浴室就在我的床边，所以我不需要穿睡袍什么的。我只是走进去，把门反锁。然后是通往走廊的门，还有那扇把淋浴间和马桶与洗手池隔开的门。很奇怪，这个浴室有三扇锁着的门，但我喜欢。如果我必须躲着谁，比如窃贼什么的，或者只是想一个人待着，我就可以进来锁上所有的门。
The shower is nice and warm when I get in, and I suck a little water into my mouth and spit it out again. I don't want to go to school today. I'm going to be in such trouble. it's like a god damn black cloud hanging over my head, like in the cartoons when it's only raining on the one guy and it follows him around wherever he goes, even indoors. That guy is me.
洗澡水热乎乎的，我吸了点水到嘴里又吐了出来。我今天不想去学校。我会惹大麻烦的。那就像一块该死的乌云悬在我的头上，就像卡通片里那样，只有一个人在下雨，无论他走到哪儿，甚至在室内，那朵云都跟着他。那个人就是我。
I run the whole thing back in my head. I did so many things wrong I can't even believe it. I shouldn't have taken the matches from Adam. I shouldn't have lit that match. I shouldn't have set the whole pack on fire. I shouldn't have thrown them in that locker. And I really shouldn't have put that lock on the locker. I'm so stupid, I say out loud, and turn off the shower. I'm going to wear all black today. I always do.
我在脑海里回放了整个过程。我做了那么多错事，简直不敢相信。我不该拿亚当的火柴。我不该点那根火柴。我不该把整包火柴点着。我不该把它们扔进那个储物柜里。我真的不该把那个锁挂在储物柜上。我真蠢，我大声说着，关掉了淋浴喷头。我今天打算全身黑。我总是这样。
Downstairs my dad would be drinking coffee, staring at the paper. But he's on a business trip so there's a big hole at the breakfast table. My brother's still in his room getting ready for high school. But he can leave late because his friend Schmid picks him up. My mother's moving around the kitchen, cleaning things up. She puts my lunch bag on the counter. She doesn't write my name on it.
楼下，我爸爸通常会喝着咖啡，盯着报纸看。但他出差了，所以早餐桌上有一个巨大的空缺。我弟弟还在房间里准备去高中。但他可以晚点走，因为他朋友施密德会接他。我妈妈在厨房走动，收拾东西。她把我的午餐袋放在柜台上。她没在上面写我的名字。
When the bus comes, I get on and walk all the way to the back. There's still a seat next to Anna, the girl from down the street. I sit and turn my body just enough so I can slide my hand under Anna's sweater. At first she doesn't move. But when my hand touches her belly she exhales really loud and whispers, it's too cold. I take my hand back, rub it and blow on it until it's warm. And then I slide it back under her sweater and rub my thumb against the rough fabric of her bra and the top of her breast. Sometimes, I ask her how it comes undone and she says, it's a latch on the front. And I spend the rest of the ride trying to figure out what that means. And once I noticed a hole in the crotch of her pants and I tried to put my finger in it. But she said it tickled too much. Today I'm happy just to feel the warmth of her skin. When we get to school, I pull my hand from under her shirt and get off as fast as I can.
校车来的时候，我上了车，一直走到最后面。安娜旁边还有一个位子，就是街那头那个女孩。我坐下，身体转过去一点，好把手滑进安娜的毛衣下。起初她没动。但当我的手碰到她的肚子时，她大声呼气，低声说，太凉了。我把手拿回来，搓了搓，吹了吹，直到它暖和起来。然后我又把它滑回她的毛衣下，用大拇指蹭着她胸罩粗糙的布料和她乳房的顶部。有时，我会问她那是怎么解开的，她说，前面有个钩子。我花了大半个路程在琢磨这意味着什么。有一次我注意到她裤裆有个洞，我想把手指伸进去。但她说太痒了。今天，我只是满足于感受她皮肤的温度。到了学校，我把手从她衬衫下抽出来，尽可能快地下了车。
My best friend Steven and I are in home room together because both of our last names begin with R. And that makes it the most fun class of the day, which sucks because it's also the first. We sit in the back row, holding copies of The Catcher in the Rye , which I haven't read, but I might read because I like books about baseball, and whisper about Megan. I say, did you call her? Yeah. Did you ask her out? Yeah. What did she say? She said maybe. Maybe? I ask. She said she kind of likes someone else. Who? I ask. You. This is bad news because I know how much Steven likes her. And I'm sure she likes him back. Why do I have to screw everything up? I'm such a freaking idiot.
我和我最好的朋友史蒂芬在同一个自习室，因为我们的姓都以R开头。这使它成为一天中最有趣的课，这很糟糕，因为它也是第一节课。我们坐在后排，拿着《麦田里的守望者》，我还没读过，但我可能会读，因为我喜欢关于棒球的书，我们低声谈论着梅根。我说，你给她打电话了吗？嗯。你约她了吗？嗯。她说什么？她说也许吧。也许？我问。她说她好像喜欢别人。谁？我问。你。这是个坏消息，因为我知道史蒂芬有多喜欢她。而且我敢肯定她也喜欢他。为什么我非得把一切搞砸？我真是个该死的白痴。
Mike and I sit in the back row of Mr. Wolf's civics class, figuring out how to spin a pencil between our fingers like Iceman does in Top Gun . Leah sits in front of us and pays attention to Mr. Wolf the whole time. She used to write notes to me, asking who I liked, and dropped them onto my desk. I'd write back, asking her if she wanted to join my religion, the Ace of Spades. Back in seventh grade, I had a lot of time on my hands. And I'd come up with crazy ideas just to freak people out. I came up with the idea about a religion based around a god called the Ace of Spades. And we'd all worship the Ace. And he'd be the one true creator and always wear black. But I never really figured out how to make people believe that he was the one true creator. So I sort of gave the whole thing up.
迈克和我坐在沃尔夫先生公民课的后排，琢磨着怎么像《壮志凌云》里的冰人那样在手指间转动铅笔。利亚坐在我们前面，全程关注着沃尔夫先生。她过去常给我写纸条，问我喜欢谁，扔在我的桌子上。我会写回信，问她想不想加入我的宗教——黑桃A教。七年级的时候，我闲得没事干。我会想出一些疯狂的点子来吓唬别人。我想出了一个以一个叫“黑桃A”的神为基础的宗教。我们都会崇拜黑桃A。他会是唯一的真神，总是穿黑色。但我从没真正想出怎么让人相信他是唯一的真神。所以我基本上放弃了整件事。
Leah always thought I was a freak for talking about things like that. But she used to at least pay attention. Now she just ignores me, maybe because of the time she got a B plus on her report card and started crying because it was the first time she'd gotten anything lower than an A, and I called her a stupid bitch for crying about something so stupid. I used to get all A's too. And now I'm getting F's in a couple of classes. And my parents think I'm a retard. But you don't see me crying about it.
利亚总觉得我是个怪胎，因为我谈论那些东西。但她过去至少会关注我。现在她只是无视我，也许是因为有一次她的成绩单上得了个B+，她就开始哭，因为那是她第一次得到低于A的成绩，我骂她是个为了这么蠢的事而哭的蠢货。我过去也总是得A。而现在我在几门课上得的是F。我父母认为我是个弱智。但你没见我因为这个哭。
I meet up with my friend Adam halfway down Main Hall, and we walk to gym together. He says, I swear, man, did you see Katherine in that sweater? She's so stacked, especially for a seventh grader. Yeah, I guess. I'm not even thinking about that stuff today. I've got bigger things on my mind.
我在走廊中间遇到了我的朋友亚当，我们一起走向健身房。他说，我发誓，哥们，你看到凯瑟琳那件毛衣了吗？她胸部太有料了，尤其是对七年级学生来说。是啊，我想吧。我今天根本没心思考虑那些。我有更重要的事情要担心。
Friday in gym, when me and a bunch of guys were changing, dropping our pants and pulling up our green gym shorts as fast as we could, Adam got out a book of matches he'd gotten from the 7-11 and showed them to me. I don't know why, but I grabbed them and lit one. And then because I thought it would be funny to see everybody's reaction, I set the whole pack on fire. And all of a sudden there was a big ball of fire in my hand and I didn't know what to do. So I opened one of the lockers and threw the burning thing in. Then I realized there was a shirt in the locker. I panicked when I realized that the shirt had caught fire too, and I grabbed a loose lock from the bench and put it on the locker, thinking that it would put out the flames. And then I ran over to the water fountain, cupped some water between my hands, and carried it back to the burning locker. I tried to throw it through the metal slats, but by that time the shirt had just about burned itself out, and then my problem was the smoke.
周五上体育课时，我和一群男生在更衣室，脱下裤子，以最快的速度穿上绿色的体育短裤。亚当拿出从7-11便利店买的一包火柴给我看。我不知道为什么，我抢过来点燃了一根。然后因为我觉得看大家反应会很有趣，我就把整包火柴点着了。突然，我手里变成了一个大火球，我不知道该怎么办。所以我打开了一个储物柜，把着火的东西扔了进去。然后我意识到柜子里有一件衬衫。当发现衬衫也着火时，我慌了，我从长椅上抓起一把没锁的锁，锁在柜门上，以为能把火灭掉。然后我跑到饮水机旁，用手捧着水，跑回正在燃烧的柜子那里。我试图把水扔进金属条缝里，但那时候衬衫已经烧得差不多了，然后我的问题变成了烟味。
By that time, all the other guys had already gone out to gym and I was the only one left in the locker room. So I just opened all the windows to get the smell of burning cotton out, and then went out and played volleyball. When we came back in at the end of the period to change, you could still smell the smoke, but the gym teacher just thought somebody had been smoking.
那时候，其他男生都已经去上体育课了，我是唯一留在更衣室的人。所以我只是打开了所有的窗户散掉烧焦棉布的味道，然后出去打排球了。课结束我们回来换衣服时，还能闻到烟味，但体育老师只是以为有人偷偷吸烟。
But when I walk into gym today, I can see Mr. Huff is standing in the back of the locker room, right next to the locker that was on fire. He keeps moving his bottom lip over his mustache, so it looks like he's trying to eat it. He says, OK, boys, settle down. On Friday there was an incident in the locker room. Some arsonist among you purposely set a shirt on fire. We had the fire chief come over and investigate. He took some fingerprints and we expect the results later today. Boys, whoever did this is an enormous amount of trouble. Charges will be pressed. He'll be expelled. But now I'm prepared to give the guilty party a chance to confess. So whoever did it, or if you know who did it, come see me in my office before the end of the period. His eyes lock with mine on the last word and I feel a cold sickness all over my body.
但今天当我走进健身房时，我看到哈夫先生正站在更衣室后面，就在那个着火的储物柜旁边。他不停地用下嘴唇蹭着胡子，看起来像是在试图吃掉它。他说，好了，小伙子们，安静。周五在更衣室发生了一起事件。你们中间有纵火犯故意烧了一件衬衫。我们请消防队长来调查了。他提取了一些指纹，我们预计今天晚些时候会有结果。孩子们，不管是谁做的，都摊上大麻烦了。会被起诉。会被开除。但现在，我准备给犯错者一个坦白的机会。所以不管是谁做的，或者你知道是谁做的，课结束前到我办公室来。说到最后一个词时，他的眼睛锁住了我，我感到全身一阵冰冷。
What am I going to do? What am I going to do? I say over and over as we walk out into the gym and start stretching. We're playing dodge ball inside today because it's cold and raining. Kevin picks up the purple ball and wings it, nailing me in the back. And I go sit on the sidelines for the rest of the game. Nick beans Adam and he comes over and sits next to me. They were his matches. His fingerprints were on them too.
我该怎么办？我该怎么办？我们走出健身房开始伸展运动时，我一遍又一遍地说。因为天冷下雨，我们今天在室内玩躲避球。凯文捡起紫球，猛地掷过来，正中我的后背。我坐在边线上看完了剩下的比赛。尼克砸中了亚当，他走过来坐在我旁边。那是他的火柴。上面也有他的指纹。
What are you going to do? He says. I don't know, I say. Are you going to turn yourself in? No. You're not? No. What are you going to do? He asks. I'm going to kill myself. You are? Yeah. But how will they know it was you, not me? I don't know, I guess I'll write a note saying I  did it. You will? And he gets up and starts to walk away, and then calls out, Hey, thanks.
你打算怎么办？他说。我不知道，我说。你要自首吗？不。你真的不？不。你打算怎么办？他问。我要自杀。真的？是。但他们怎么会知道是我干的，而不是你？我不知道，我想我会写张字条说是我干的。你会吗？他站起来准备走，然后喊道，嘿，谢了。
Brian and I sit in the back row during English. Sometimes we draw Motley Crue and Aerosmith symbols on our notebooks. He likes me because I tell him what the books are about when he doesn't read them. Brian, I say, could the cops-- the cops couldn't get fingerprints from a book of matches if it were all burnt up, could they? He thinks for a second. He knows this kind of thing. Yeah, they could. They could? Yeah, because fire doesn't burn away fingerprints. It doesn't? No. Unless the person who lit the matches also poured lighter fluid or some other emollient like gasoline or something on the matches. Then they wouldn't be able to find anything. But, like, the school doesn't have our fingerprints on file, does it? Yeah, of course they do. They have everybody's fingerprints on file. They do? I slide a little lower in my seat. I'm so screwed. Yeah, he says. Don't you know anything?
布莱恩和我在英语课坐后排。有时我们在笔记本上画克鲁小丑乐队和空中铁匠乐队的符号。他喜欢我，因为我不看书的时候会告诉他书里讲什么。布莱恩，我说，警察能——如果火柴全烧坏了，警察不可能从中提取指纹吧？他想了一会儿。他懂行。不，他们能。能吗？能，因为火烧不掉指纹。真的？不。除非点火柴的人还在火柴上倒了打火机油或其他润滑剂，比如汽油之类的。那样他们就查不到了。但是，学校没有留存我们的指纹，对吧？有，当然有。他们有所有人的指纹存档。真的吗？我缩回座位里。我死定了。是啊，他说。你什么都不知道吗？
These days in Algebra, I have to sit up front with the brains. I used to sit in the back with Nick and Kevin, two of the coolest kids in school. We'd open Mrs. Loftus's file cabinets when she wasn't looking, and steal school supplies. We got white out and pencils and big yellow legal pads. And we'd take them back to Kevin's locker and store them there. We never used them or anything. We just liked stealing. I don't know how they figured out it was us. Kevin thinks they installed a security camera, but I'm not sure.
最近在代数课上，我得坐在前面和聪明人待在一起。我过去常和尼克、凯文坐在后面，他们是学校里最酷的两个孩子。趁洛夫图斯夫人不注意，我们会打开她的文件柜，偷学校用品。我们拿到了涂改液、铅笔和厚黄色律师记录纸。我们把它们带回凯文的柜子里存着。我们从不用它们，只是喜欢偷窃。我不知道他们是怎么查出来是我们干的。凯文认为是他们装了监控摄像头，但我也不确定。
The night before the school called my parents, I got dressed up in my best outfit-- a black blazer, black silk shirt, black dress pants, and a black tie-- and lay in my bed listening to Warrant's "Cherry Pie" album. I took my kitchen knife from its hiding place between the mattress and box spring and held it against my wrist. When the music got really loud I sliced as fast as I could and bit my lip from the pain. I hung my arm between the two twin beds pushed together, from when my brother used to share the room with me, and let it bleed.
学校通知我父母的前一天晚上，我穿上我最帅的衣服——黑色西装外套、黑色真丝衬衫、黑色西裤和黑色领带——躺在床上听Warrant乐队的《Cherry Pie》专辑。我从床垫和弹簧床箱之间的藏身处取出厨房刀，对着手腕。音乐声非常大时，我用力切下去，咬着嘴唇忍着痛。我把手臂悬在两张并在一起的单人床上，我弟弟过去跟我住一个房间时用的，让血流出来。
I was surprised when I woke up in the morning. My blood had clotted into the carpet. I had to find a Band-Aid big enough to cover the wound, and I told my parents I had scratched my wrist on a locker.
早上醒来时我很惊讶。血已经在地毯上凝固了。我得找一块够大的创可贴盖住伤口，我告诉父母我是被储物柜划伤的。
We got three days in school suspension for stealing and my parents were pissed. They sat me down at the kitchen table and told me how upset they were. Just the looks on their faces was terrible. My dad was scowling at me like I was a hoodlum. My mom looked like I'd broken her heart. It was like they didn't recognize me. They said, we've never been so disappointed in you. I promised them I'd do better, and I tried. I wonder how they'll feel when I get expelled.
因为偷窃我们被停课三天，我父母气坏了。他们让我坐在餐桌旁，告诉我他们有多失望。那样子看着真让人难受。我爸爸怒视着我，好像我是个小流氓。我妈妈看起来就像我伤了她的心。就好像他们不认识我了。他们说，我们从来没有对你这么失望过。我向他们保证我会表现得更好，我尝试了。我不知道当他们发现我被开除时会作何感想。
I see Steven in the hall on the way to lunch. I pull him over next to the blue lockers out of the way of the crowd and say, I'm in big trouble. Why? he asks. I lit a book of matches on fire in gym and burned somebody's shirt up. That was you? Yeah. That was my shirt. It was? Yeah. Why'd you do that? I don't know, I was just screwing around. That was your shirt? Yeah. What are you going to do? They took fingerprints. I know. I don't know what I'm going to do. I walk down the  hall towards the cafeteria and I know that I'm completely screwed.
我去吃午饭的路上在大厅看到了史蒂芬。我把他拽到蓝色储物柜旁，避开人群说，我摊上大事了。为什么？他问。我在健身房把一盒火柴点着了，烧了谁的衬衫。那个人是你？嗯。那是我的衬衫。真的？嗯。为什么你要这么做？我不知道，我只是在胡闹。那是你的衬衫？嗯。你打算怎么办？他们提取了指纹。我知道。我不知道该怎么办。我朝食堂走去，知道自己彻底完了。
I think about that movie we saw in English class, about the guy who's standing on the bridge waiting to get hung. I wonder why all the ways I've tried to kill myself haven't worked. I mean, I tried hanging. I used to have a noose tied to my closet pole. I'd go in there and slip the thing over my head and let my weight go. But every time I started to lose consciousness, I'd just stand up. I tried to take pills. I took 20 Advil one afternoon, but that just made me sleepy. And all the times I tried to cut my wrists I could never cut deep enough. That's the thing. Your body tries to keep you alive no matter what you do. During drama class, they finally call me into the vice principal's office. She's wearing a red dress that I can't stop looking at. She asks if I know anything about the fire, and I tell her no. She stares at me for a few seconds and says, you can go. She knows that I did it.
我想到我们在英语课上看的那部电影，关于那个站在桥上等待绞刑的家伙。我奇怪为什么我试过的所有自杀方式都不管用。我是说，我试过上吊。我的壁橱杆上曾经系过一个绳套。我会钻进去，把东西套在脖子上，让自己垂下来。但每次我快要失去意识时，我就站起来了。我试过吃药。一天下午我吃了20片安乃近，但那只是让我困倦。我所有试过割腕的时候，都无法切得足够深。问题就在这。无论你怎么做，你的身体都在试图让你活下去。戏剧课上，他们终于把我叫到了副校长办公室。她穿着一件让我盯着看个不停的红裙子。她问我知不知道火灾的事，我告诉她不。她盯着我看了几秒钟说，你可以走了。她知道是我干的。
When seventh period is finally over, I run to my locker and put all my books inside. I won't need them anymore. I grab my lock picking set and a spare Ace of Spades that I have lying around. I touch Michelle Pfeiffer's lips with my thumb. At the end of the hallway, I can see Steven talking to Megan, the girl we both have a crush on. I walk up to them and say hi. She smiles at me and I try to smile back. Steven looks a little suspicious. I don't want to tell them what I'm going to do. I hand him the Ace of Spades and say, goodbye. And I walk away. I hope they'll be happy together. I see my friend Jake at his locker and give him the lock picking set. Use them wisely, I say, and head towards the bus.
第七节课终于结束时，我跑回柜子，把所有的书放进去。我再也不需要它们了。我拿上开锁工具和随身带的备用黑桃A扑克牌。我用拇指抚摸米歇尔·菲佛的嘴唇。在走廊尽头，我能看到史蒂芬在和梅根说话，就是我们俩都暗恋的那个女孩。我走过去打招呼。她对我微笑，我试着回以微笑。史蒂芬看起来有点怀疑。我不想告诉他们我要做什么。我把黑桃A交给他说，再见。然后我走开了。我希望他们能幸福。我看到我的朋友杰克在柜子那儿，把开锁工具递给了他。明智地使用它们，我说，然后朝校车走去。
Laura walks with me down D Hall. She says, hey, I heard you set that fire in gym class. What are you going to do? I'm going to set myself on fire. She stops at her locker, but I keep walking. On the bus ride home, I sit by myself. I lean my head against the cold, glass window, and try not to think about all the stupid things I've done and all the pain I've caused everyone.
劳拉陪我沿着D厅走。她说，嘿，我听说你在体育课纵火了。你打算怎么办？我要把自己点着。她在她的储物柜那儿停下，但我继续走。在回家校车上，我独自坐着。我把头靠在冰冷的玻璃窗上，试图不去想我做的那些蠢事以及我给每个人带来的痛苦。
My brother Craig is playing basketball outside the house when I get home. He's shooting free throws. I rebound the ball for him and throw it back. I don't want to take any shots. I tell him the whole story about what I did and what they're going to do to me. I don't tell him what I'm going to do to myself. When I'm done talking he says, that sucks. And I go inside the house. I don't have to write a note anymore, because Craig knows everything.
我到家时，我弟弟克雷格正在屋外打篮球。他在投罚球。我为他抢篮板并扔回去。我不想投篮。我告诉了他我做了什么以及他们要对我做什么的整个故事。我没告诉他我要对自己做什么。我说完后他说，那真倒霉。然后我进屋了。我不需要再写字条了，因为克雷格什么都知道。
I walk out to the shed to get the gas can. I bring it inside, upstairs to the bathroom, because that's the room with the most locks. I go back downstairs and get the matches from the kitchen. I take off all my clothes and put on the pair of red boxers with the glow-in-the-dark lips that my mom bought me at the mall last weekend. I bring the bathrobe into the shower and I pour the gasoline all over it. The gas can is only about a quarter full but it seems like enough.
我走到棚子里拿汽油桶。我把它拿进屋，带上楼进浴室，因为那是锁最多的房间。我又下楼从厨房拿了火柴。我脱掉所有衣服，换上了我妈上周末在商场给我买的那条带夜光嘴唇图案的红色平角内裤。我把浴袍带进淋浴间，把汽油倒在上面。汽油桶只有四分之一满，但似乎足够了。
I step into the bathtub and I put the bathrobe over my shoulders. It's wet and heavy, but there's something kind of comforting about the smell, like going on a long car trip. I hold the box of matches out in front of me in my left hand. I take out a blue tip match and hold it against the box. Should I do it? Yes. Do it. I strike the match. But it doesn't light. Try again. I light the match. Nothing happens. I bring it closer to my wrist and then it goes up, all over me, eating through me everywhere. I can't breathe. I'm screaming. Craig, Craig.
我跨进浴缸，把浴袍披在肩上。它又湿又重，但那气味有一种让人安慰的感觉，就像去长途旅行一样。我左手拿着那盒火柴。我抽出一根蓝头火柴，抵在盒子上。我该做吗？是的。去做吧。我擦燃了火柴。但它没着。再试一次。我点燃了火柴。什么也没发生。我把它靠近手腕，然后它燃起来了，瞬间蔓延全身，到处啃食着我。我无法呼吸。我在尖叫。克雷格，克雷格。
I fall down. I'm going to die. I'm going to find out what death is like. I'm going to know. But nothing's happening. This hurts too much. I need to stop it. I need to get up. I stand. I don't know how I stand, but I do. And I turn on the shower. I unlock the door with my hand and open it. My hand is all black.
我倒下了。我要死了。我要知道死亡是什么样子了。我要知道了。但什么都没发生。这太痛了。我得停下来。我得站起来。我站了起来。我不知道我是怎么站起来的，但我做到了。我打开了淋浴。我用手解锁了门，推开它。我的手全是黑的。
I walk out. There's Craig with Rusty, our dog, next him. They have the same expression on their faces.
我走了出去。克雷格和我们的狗拉斯蒂在旁边。它们脸上都有同样的表情。
Craig yells something and runs downstairs. He's calling 9-1-1. He hands me the phone and runs off. There's a woman on the phone asking questions. I try to tell her what's happened but there's something wrong with my voice. The woman on the phone says the fire trucks and ambulances are on their way. Somehow she knows my address. There's smoke coming from the bathroom upstairs and I can see that the whole room has turned black. If the room is black, then why am I OK? And I look down and see my flesh is charred and flaky. And the glow-in-the-dark boxer shorts are burnt into my skin. The woman on the phone says everything's going to be all right. She keeps asking me if I'm still on fire and I say, I-- I don't think so.
克雷格大喊一声，跑下楼。他在打911。他把电话递给我然后跑开了。电话那头有个女人在问问题。我试图告诉她发生了什么，但我的声音出了点问题。电话里的女人说消防车和救护车正在赶来。不知怎么她知道我的地址。楼上浴室有烟冒出来，我能看出整个房间都变黑了。如果房间是黑的，那为什么我没事？我低头看去，看到我的肉被烧焦了，起皮了。那条夜光内裤烧进了我的皮肤里。电话里的女人说一切都会好起来的。她一直问我身上还在着火吗，我说，我——我不觉得。
I'm walking around the kitchen, waiting for the ambulance to come. I can see my reflection in the microwave. That's not me. That's not my face. That's not what I look like. Where's my hair? Where did my hair go? We used to put marshmallows in microwave. We used to watch them get bigger and bigger and then shrink down. Oh God, just tell them to get here. Just tell them to get here, OK? I just need them to get here. She says, they're coming. They're almost there. I'm so sorry, I say. I'm so sorry. It's OK. That's OK.
我在厨房里走来走去，等着救护车。我能看到微波炉里我的倒影。那不是我。那不是我的脸。我看起来不是那样的。我的头发呢？我的头发去哪了？我们过去常把棉花糖放进微波炉。我们常看它们变得越来越大，然后又缩小。噢上帝，告诉他们快到这来。只要告诉他们快到这来，好吗？我需要他们快到这来。她说，他们来了。快到了。对不起，我说。我非常抱歉。没事。没事的。
I can hear the sirens in the distance now. It hurts to talk. I think there's something wrong in my throat. I say, I want to lie down. I'm going to lie down. You can't lie down. But I have to. The men are here. The firemen are here. They're putting me on a plastic sheet. They say I'm going to be OK. One of them puts something over my face. That feels good. That feels so good. The cold air feels so good going into my lungs. What are they talking about? What are they saying? They're giving me a shot. They say it's going to make the pain go away.
我能听到远处的警报声了。说话很痛。我想我的喉咙出问题了。我说，我想躺下。我要躺下。你不能躺下。但我必须。男人们来了。消防员来了。他们把我放在一张塑料布上。他们说我会没事的。其中一个人把什么东西罩在我脸上。感觉真好。感觉真好。冷空气进入肺里的感觉真好。他们在说什么？他们在说什么？他们给我打了一针。他们说这会减轻疼痛。
I'm looking at the faces of all the men who are gathered around me, and their eyes are so blue and clear. My brother is yelling in the background and punching the walls. He's so angry. I'm being lifted. They're rolling me through the front door, down the path, and into the ambulance. I wonder if anybody in the neighborhood is watching. I don't want them to know.
我看着周围那些男人的脸，他们的眼睛是那么蓝那么清澈。我弟弟在背景里大喊大叫，捶打着墙。他太愤怒了。我被抬了起来。他们把我推过前门，沿着小路，进了救护车。我不知道附近有没有人在看。我不想让他们知道。
And then my mom is here. And she's smiling and saying she loves me. And her eyes, which are green like my eyes, are the most beautiful thing I've ever seen.
然后我妈妈在这儿了。她在微笑，说她爱我。她的眼睛，像我的眼睛一样是绿色的，是我见过最美丽的景象。
Brent Runyon. His account of this time in his life is collected in a memoir called The Burn Journals . He also has a new book called Surface Tension: A Novel in Four Summers.
布伦特·鲁尼恩。他在这段生活时期的记录收录在回忆录《烧伤日记》中。他还有一本新书，叫《表面张力：四个夏天的虚构小说》。
Adrianne Mathiowetz runs our website. Our production manager is Seth Lind. Production help from Andy Dixon. Production help on the runaway story from Ellen Yuan and Rhonda Bernstein. It was part of the World Views series, a collection of first-person narratives. Some of that funding came from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting.
艾德里安·马西奥韦茨负责我们的网站。我们的制片经理是塞斯·林德。安迪·狄克逊提供制作协助。逃跑故事的制作协助来自艾伦·袁和朗达·伯恩斯坦。它是《世界景观》系列的一部分，该系列收集了第一人称叙事作品。部分资金来自公共广播公司。
Our website, where you can get tickets to our movie theater event, for one night only. Thursday, April 23 we're going to do an episode of our radio show live on stage and beam it to movie theaters all over the country. Tickets are available at thisamericanlife.org. A shout out to my own dad, with apologies for my own teenage years. I am very glad we are all older now.
我们的网站，在那里您可以购买我们电影院活动的门票，仅此一场。4月23日星期四，我们将现场直播一集广播节目，并将其投影到全国各地的电影院。门票可在thisamericanlife.org购买。向我自己的父亲致敬，并为我自己的青少年时代表示歉意。我很高兴我们现在都长大了。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International. WBEZ management oversight for our program by our boss, Mr. Torey Malatia, who explains what attracted him to public radio in the first place.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。WBEZ管理层对我们的节目进行监督，监督人是我们的老板，托里·马拉蒂亚先生，他解释了是什么吸引他最初进入公共广播行业。
I got into it purely for the angry, drunk, violent aspect of it.
我进入这一行纯粹是因为它那愤怒、酗酒、暴力的方面。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带着更多的《美国生活》故事。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。